SPEAKER: Now more
than ever, buyers
are turning to cloud
marketplaces to fulfill
their procurement needs.
As marketplaces are
poised to capture
a significant percentage
of the $230 billion
SaaS and Cloud software
market in 2021,
learn how you can purchase
multiple solution types--
SaaS, VMs, containers,
datasets, and APIs--
on Google Cloud Marketplace
that are vetted by Google Cloud
to cover your
enterprise's IT needs.
All of this with a single bill
and the ease of deployment
you've never seen before.
Google Cloud Marketplace is
a modern procurement platform
offering a diverse selection
of security, database,
networking solutions, and more.
This video will walk you through
how Google Cloud Marketplace
improves your IT solution
buying experience
and empowers your
procurement team to procure
and fulfill fast with a
single bill from Google.
The Marketplace has
both Google Cloud
products and partner
solutions to ensure you
can find exactly what you need.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's begin by navigating
to the Marketplace.
There are three ways to do this.
If you're not logged in to
the Google Cloud console,
you can access the
Marketplace homepage by typing
in cloud.google.com/marketplace,
or just searching for Google
Cloud Marketplace.
If you are in your
console, you'll
see the Marketplace in
the left navigation bar.
One final way to access
the Marketplace is via
what's called a [? cameo. ?]
[? Cameos ?] show
the Marketplace in the context
of your current console
location, offering a Marketplace
experience that is personalized
to your needs.
Once you reach the Marketplace
homepage, browse anonymously,
or if you're interested
in purchasing or seeing
what you have deployed, log in
using your Google credentials.
If you know what
you're looking for,
the Search bar is in
the center of the page,
or you can browse
shelves that showcase
the different
solutions available.
We keep these shelves fresh.
For instance, we were
the first marketplace
to add a COVID-19 dataset.
The other shelves
here feature commonly
searched for solution
areas, such as VMs,
GCP services, SaaS, OS,
DevStacks, et cetera.
On the left side,
you'll see filters.
These include different types
of products and categories,
as well as industries,
which are new.
And we're constantly adding
more to help you easily
find the right solutions.
Google Cloud products can be
found under the Google Cloud
Platform filter.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's say you want to
browse virtual machines.
Begin by clicking Virtual
Machines to see the VM
solutions we have before
filtering further.
Let's say we want to look
for load balancing Ubuntu.
From here, you can explore
a solution in more detail.
We're going to go ahead and
click on the second one here.
NGINX Plus Basic, Ubuntu 18.04.
The right column provides
the technical specs,
such as what the solution
runs on and its type.
Further down the
Overview page, there's
more information about the
solution and company, a pricing
table, tutorials and
documentation, training
and support, and the
terms of service.
Many VM solutions
have free trials
which are listed at the top.
Like this one says,
"30-day Trial Available."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's take a look at
a SaaS solution next.
Search for NetApp
and let autocomplete
suggest NetApp Cloud
Volume Service.
Click on the first option here.
As with the VM solution, this
page outlines technical specs.
And further down
the Overview page,
there's more information about
the solution and company,
a pricing table, tutorials
and documentation, training
and support, and the
terms of service.
Let's go ahead and hit Purchase.
Note that only users
that are billing
admins and at least a project
viewer will be able to do this.
Once you have
clicked Purchase, you
can select a plan, preferred
usage fees and specs, and more.
On the right side,
there's a pricing slider
to help you more accurately
calculate the overall cost.
At the bottom are
the terms of service.
We're looking at building
custom user license
agreements directly
within the Marketplace.
But for now you'll see the
terms of the partner and GCP.
When you Subscribe,
your order will
go to the vendor for approval.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Next, we're going to look at
what we call Private Offers.
We know that many developers
purchase pay as you
go solutions to try them out.
And then if the
trial goes well, they
will want to purchase
the solution.
With Private Offers, you
can get negotiated prices
from the partner
via the Marketplace.
From the Details
page, click Contact
to get in touch
with the partners
to start negotiating an offer.
Once the price is negotiated,
the partner simply
needs to access their
Marketplace Partner Portal
and fill in the relevant
details to create your discount.
When this is saved, a URL
will be generated, which
the vendor will email to you.
To do this, the
customer will need
to have billing admin
rights and at least
be a viewer on the project.
One additional benefit
is that these purchases
count towards your Google
Cloud Commit drawdown.
We're continuously
gathering feedback
and improving the flow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now if you go back to
the Marketplace homepage,
click on Your Solutions to view
information about everything
that you've purchased.
This page shows
you what you need
to activate, what's
failed, what's expired,
what's currently
running, and more.
We're revamping this page
to include order management
related tasks here, as well.
If you click on the hamburger
menu on the top left and hit
Billing, you'll see all the info
about how you're being billed.
You can see how much
you're spending every month
and what you're forecasted
to spend this month.
If you click View Report,
you can drill down further
by project, or even
change to group
by SKU for a deeper
understanding of billing cost.
We also provide the
option to add solutions
to a private catalog,
an enterprise governance
tool that enables admins to
take content from Marketplace.
The private catalog
provides a tool for admins
to add pre-approved
solutions that
have been vetted and
verified and follow
their internal governance
and compliance policies.
These solutions can come
from the Marketplace
or can be internally
created solutions.
Enterprise customers
then have a single place
to discover approved
solutions that they
can deploy knowing the solutions
have been approved and verified
by their Cloud admin.
Here you can see an example of
a private catalog, which looks
and feels like the Marketplace.
Ready to get going?
Don't forget to
leverage the $300 credit
that Google Cloud currently
offers to get started.
Begin by exploring more
than 2,000 solutions
available on Google
Cloud Marketplace today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]